hi hi everyone
um I'd like to start a so good evening
and welcome to today's theoretically
speaking uh talk on what do the theory
of computing and movies have in common I
think you are the answer
um anyway we'll see
I'm Shafi goldwasser I'm the director of
the Simons Institute for the theory of
computing and just a few words about the
Simons Institute we're an international
venue for collaborative research in
theoretical pure science we're
established in 2012 with a very generous
Grant from the Simons foundation and our
mission is to bring together world's
leading researchers in theoretical pure
science and related field and with
particular emphasis on the next
generation of outstanding young scholars
postdoc students to explore sort of laws
of computation and the use of algorithms
in science exact live social and
engineering
and uh today's uh talk is part of our
theoretically speaking series which
reaches mostly to the public and
highlights uh stories and advances of
theory of computing uh for a broad
audience and we're extremely fortunate
to have Alvey today Alvey Ray Smith is
our speaker and I'm going to give you a
short description uh of what I
um of the highlight of his career what
I'll brace myself you'll brace yourself
uh he actually uh got his PhD at
Stanford University computer science
department and then he was a computer
science professor at NYU and also at
Berkeley working on cellular automata
Theory which is where our theory of
computing the story starts and from
there on he went on to New York
Institute of Technology were invented
really the first color pixels followed
by
a path that led him eventually to
lucasfilm where he was the Studio's
first director of computer graphics and
I think he directed also the first
computer generated animated short film
called Adventures of Andre in Raleigh B
which I understand was sort of a Prelude
the previous name was my Dinner with
Andre
yeah one of the movies that I found
very difficult to watch but in any case
uh
um but it's a personal thing and he went
on to co-found Pixar and after that
Altamira software which eventually was
brought by Microsoft and I love a quote
that I read actually in a New York
article by Allison gopnick where she
mentions Alvey and that when you left
New York then went to California I
assume this is the correct uh quote you
said something well something good will
happen and that resonates with me
personally the idea of going back from
the east coast of California and RV
received the ACMC graph computer
Graphics award to Scientific engineering
awards from The Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Science he's a member
of nae aaas and received the honorary
doctorates from New Mexico State
University and New York Institute of
Technology and he's the creator
co-creator of many pieces of computer
art including
Sunstone which is in the new Earth
Museum of Modern Art I published widely
both in thread computer science computer
Graphics he's the author of a biography
of the pixel and one of his face first
and most famous pieces as far as I'm
concerned is his drawing of synapse
which was used as a cover of the fox
proceeding for 41 years and for those
who don't know Fox stands for
foundations of computer science
Symposium and I think it was the one
first conference I've ever want gone to
and that's the picture on our poster and
I'm delighted to announce that Alvey has
generously gifted The Institute with
their original artwork for this drawing
and we will be installing This
Magnificent contribution in our
Institute later this year so we're
deeply
um grateful to you for your generosity
and I know that for you it was like ah
just take it but for us it means quite a
bit
and speak of generous generosity I also
of course want to thank the Simons
foundation for their ongoing support and
for our industry Partners including
algor and apple Google JP Morgan and TT
research VMware Rock 360 and they enable
us to do this programming like uh this
evening's event and all our programs and
finally uh I want to thank also people
who contribute to our first annual fund
which ended in December and of course we
are welcoming all the gifts also in the
future you don't have to wait for
December so without further Ado please
join me in a warmly welcoming Ray Smith
thank you
and everybody hear me is this working
it's all the sound working
okay hi this is kind of
a little different talk than I used to
get so I'm looking forward to it
um
you can't hear me not very well all
right are we miked up should I talk into
this guy that's it all right
[Applause]
um
it's good to me that's me okay
can you hear yeah can you hear it yeah
yeah okay I'm supposed to be able to
walk around you still hear me okay all
right
um I'm going to start off with
three tributes one is to Art in general
this is like the oldest piece of art I
know right here Human Art it's also
animation
isn't it astonishing that over 20 000
years ago
in Altamira cave somebody painted an
animated boar
so I use Photoshop to break it into two
frames to see how how good a job you did
and it didn't do too bad
now for the life of me so I used to
think well maybe they use the flickering
fire to to animate it but I couldn't
make any sense out of that but I think
they just imagined my second tribute is
to my Uncle George in Las Cruces who
no longer with us but I grew up in Las
Cruces New Mexico one of my two
hometowns in New Mexico and he taught he
was a painter this is his piece a
self-portrait he taught me how to paint
with oils and acrylics when I was a
little kid the only relative he would
allow into his art studio if I was set
on the floor and remained absolutely
silent and it was torture but I did it
and I learned how to stretch canvas and
I learned to love turpentine and Lindsay
at oil and all that to mix having mixed
paints and stretch canvases so forth so
I painted pictures for a lot of years
basically until I discovered the
computer
and my third tribute it's probably more
meaningful than those two is to the late
Martin Davis
personal friend
my wife Allison couldn't make it tonight
because of a traffic jam but Martin
Davis and his wife Virginia were close
friends of
of
Allison and me he left up on the hill
here in Berkeley and uh I knew he was
sort of my treat when I first moved to
Berkeley to to to live with Allison the
first day I was here at msri I met
Martin Davis I said are you the Martin
Davis and he said what do you mean I
said computability and unsolvability he
says that's me I said well I thought you
lived in New York he said but I just
moved here so kind of a wonderful
welcoming gift to Berkeley who was to
meet Martin in Virginia we just lost him
both of them
and uh but I learned
in in New Mexico I I'm still kind of
astonished I was at New Mexico State
University where I did my undergraduate
there was a I took a graduate seminar
on girls incompleteness theorem we spent
the whole term going through this the
proof and somewhere in there I stumbled
on this book
so I started learning touring and the
Machine and all that
so those are my three tributes I also
mentioned I got started with computer
Computing way back you know in in early
in New Mexico in the 50s
before I left there something else
happened
I was assigned the job of designing an
antenna for the Nimbus weather satellite
that one right there
it's it's a
there's a there's a cone there you
probably can't make out but there was an
equally angular spiral painted on there
and that was the shape of the antenna
and I was the the old Engineers thought
they could keep me busy for a month
drawing that antenna and I said but a
computer can do that and they would nah
yeah I'm pretty sure
and sure enough I got the
you know I wrote a little program and
got the computers and do it overnight
and turned it in so that was my first
that was 1964 my very first computer
graphic
and also while I was still at New Mexico
State roaming around in the stacks I
stumbled on this paper
steps towards artificial intelligence by
Marvin Minsky
and I was just enthralled I said you
mean
computers might be a model for this
wow what a sexy idea I want to know more
where do I go okay so Vietnam is Vietnam
war is underway
I have to go to graduate school or I get
drafted
so I decided to go to graduate school
somewhere where they teach that
I found two places MIT and Stanford
Stanford gave me more money so that's
why I went there
now I had some problems at Stanford
I won't belabor you with but had to do
with the length of my hair but uh
um
but I stumbled into you know one of the
so one of the older professors let's
just put it this way I won't name him
had a lot of trouble linking my hair
because I was a full-blown hippie about
one year after I arrived in California
and uh
but two of the younger professors took
me under their wing and said that wasn't
fair what he did you and they they
guided me through the The Perils of
graduate school and one was Michael
larba probably know him and uh I learned
he became my PhD advisor and uh I wrote
my thesis on cellular automata and I the
the specialty was my theorem that I was
the theorem I was proudest of was I
proved the existence of a
self-reproducing self-reproducing
computation Universal
cellular automaton
and that's what this cover is supposed
to represent
that the concept was mine but the
execution of it is rather poor and I was
disappointed by it I didn't do it I did
not do the execution of his book
but I did publish it in this proceedings
the ninth switching an automata Theory
proceedings
and I also published the paper in the
next one
or two later the 11th and the 12th also
I'm not going to put that one up
the reason I'm showing you this is
because of this diagram and the paper I
put into the 11th SWAT
it's a real simple proof that a cellular
automaton can recognize the palindrome
in time equal to its length it's so
trivial I won't bother you with it but
just remember that space-time diagram
because
it led right to this
um
after my first job after Stanford was as
a assistant professor at NYU
in New York City and uh just after I'd
arrived there so you know I graduated in
69 from Stanford got my first job
immediately at NYU so about 70 I get my
copy of scientific America
I've been reading it since I was a kid
Martin Gardner's column in particular
and there was this column about The Game
of Life
and I read it and I said this is my
thesis this is cellular automata theory
he and Martin Gardner my hero doesn't
know about it
I'm going to call him
so I did he lived up the Hudson River I
called and called him and by the way I
should mention he was a underground hero
to the acid generation in San Francisco
because of his annotated Alice
is De rigor reading by every asset head
in the world I think
and uh so I had two reasons to meet this
guy and uh
I called him up says do you know about
Von Neumann and ulam and
self-reproducing machines and Garden of
Eden theorems anymore no I don't know
any of this and it's such a popular
subject
that the publisher wants to make it the
cover story in the February 71 issue
can I come down and spend time with you
and find out what you know I said sure
sure I got to spend a day with my hero
childhood Heroes just fabulous and uh he
didn't have a clue about why annotated
Alice was popular and this the culture
Gap was so large I didn't bother trying
to go across and explain it to him
because of the rest of the conversation
about math was so much fun
all right
he says okay Ali called me I vetted his
his calling for him and then he said you
know what they want to make this the
cover story so I'm going to submit some
stanislaw ulam designs
come up with some two signs
and submit them well I just published
that theorem
in Swat
recognizing palindrome in real time with
a cellular automata space-time diagram
so I came up with a just a colorized
version of it
where I chose as my palindrome
um
uh
something I had found in the New York
Times crossword puzzle
a special puzzle devoted to palindromes
the clue was why don't owls live in the
tropics
and the answer is
too hot to who
which is which is a really nice
palindrome because it's not only a
palindromes
literally because of the text but
spatially because the letters are all
vertically symmetric
so anyhow I'll back that off
all right I won the competition for that
cover why because the publisher of
Scientific American was a palindrome
freak
so and that's and I told shoffy this one
day I think that that was the first
taste of any kind of Fame I had ever had
in my life was suddenly letters were
coming in from all over the world
now they were mostly about the Game of
Life which didn't particularly excite me
but you know it I met a lot of
interesting people that way
and uh I started getting you know
I had context in a lot of different
countries all of a sudden it was it was
a lot of fun
and that led
to this
because for the
I guess it's the 14th SWAT
by the way SWAT and fox are the same
thing
it changed names early on uh SWAT for
the 14th SWAT all right so
I had thought about going to IBM Watson
Research Center rather than NYU gorgeous
place if you've ever been there it's
just an absolutely gorgeous research
facility but I was a young guy and I
wanted to live in New York City
so I chose
living in New York but I went up to
Watson a lot hung out with the guys
there
and we did rock climbing with them and
so forth Eric Wagner and Ernie Rosenberg
and Jim Thatcher and I can't remember
all the names A lot of people
that I approved theorems with
and uh Arne Rosenberg said hey Alvey
we'd like for you to design it's seen
the cover I had a different Scientific
American said we'd like for you to
design a cover for our proceedings
I went okay they sound like a good idea
I like making pictures as much as I do
math
um
and this came about one day and
uh it was a terrible day in New York
City it was deep winter
it was the north Bronx
in a in a blizzard horrible weather my
car broke down
I pulled into an Esso station it was
just a miserable it was an ugly Esso
station
it wasn't red white and blue it was red
dirty gray and blue
and it was you know it was so ugly and I
was so horrified I was gonna have to
spend hours there where my car got fixed
I said what can I do to escape this and
I said design the cover
and while I was sitting there in that
horrible situation this came to me
not completely but the idea of the my
hands synapsing onto a cellular automata
like thingy
was the basic idea that I had
it took me a month to execute it in
India Inc on vellum
using French curves and straight edges
and rapidographs and even an exacto
knife to delineate some of the inclines
and it got used
for the 14th
and
a whole lot of other
in fact it got used
for uh
Fox proceedings let's change this name
you can see to foundations of computer
science
and then three more after that I don't
think I have pictures of that
when it went electronic and then they
finally figured out oh we don't need a
cover if it's electronic so
so for 41 years it got used you know
it's by far my uh proudest achievement
in theoretical computer science
[Laughter]
uh
so you'll notice that between let's see
the 15th and the 60s that's where it
changes name so early on there
um
coincidentally the last one's in 2010
the last one shown is 2010. and the
reason I say coincidentally is because
that's when I began work on this book
that I published last year or two years
ago now
it took me 10 years to write this book I
started in 2010 and published in 2021.
and
um
the reason it took so long was every
time I touched a subject that I thought
I knew I was just going to write it down
I found out no I don't know it and not
only that but the histories had it wrong
and it would take me a year to
understand what the history really
should be of various Technologies
and to get it right I think I do it
right
and then I'll go to the next one find
the same problem okay
um
why did I write this book
well because
something really amazing happened about
the Millennium about the year 2000 and
nobody paid any attention
we have been waiting for this to happen
for years amen came it went nobody paid
it just was accepted I called it the
great digital convergence
when all old media types got swapped out
for one the bit
in the form of the bit takes and
pictures is pixel
and I remember we all knew it was coming
that the videotape was going to go away
film's going to go away
chemical wet stuff was going to go away
a ferromagnetic materials are going to
go away pigments all this stuff are
going to go away to be the bit
it happened in 2000 nobody blinked so I
wanted to celebrate that event that was
one purpose of this book how did we get
there
and then the other other reason for it
was I realized the pixel is the atom of
the new picture universe and nobody
knows what a pixel is
I got I would ask people what a pixel I
got all kinds of cockamammy answers and
I realized nobody really knows and it's
not that hard most most people think
those are pixels
no they've never been little squares
ever
it's a total misrepresentation now it's
kind of interesting why people think
that's what a pixel should be
if they're stiff and linear and squarish
and maybe people early on at least
thought computers were stiff and linear
and rigid and therefore that's what the
pixels had to look like but of course we
all know that the computation and the
computers
the most malleable tool of humankind has
ever invented there's nothing keeping it
making its pictures look like that
I think that I think the the the the
villain here is the is the zoom feature
really the zoom feature every app has a
zoom every device has a zoom you know
what does Zoom do it's a quick and dirty
trick that made sense back when
computers were slow it does the
following thing
it replace it suppose we want to
multiply you know magnify the screen by
a hundred what Zoom does
is replace each pixel with a 100 by 100
square of that copies
of copies of that pixel
so what does it look like it looks like
that when you look at a course this is
if you're looking at Square arrays
but you're not looking at the pixel left
Plus
it should be done away with it's
absolutely false
all right
so what is a pixel that's I you know
I've set out in the book to to explain
it and without math by the way I wrote
this book for
uh just to do it intuitively
so I avoid mathematical terms
I may sneak one in for you guys
uh it starts with Fourier Bridge
Revolution that's Fourier on the left
this is probably a more accurate picture
of it
May contemporaneously
um
and Napoleon's is his Tyrant on the
right so I kind of came up with this
historical theme that seemed to be
repeated when it comes to histories of
Technology there's a great idea there's
some kind of chaos that drives it into
fruition and there's some Tyrant or
tyranny that
does all the wrong things but somehow
helps it happen anyhow
and that's the case here Fourier
was a
well you know I grew up in double e we
didn't have Peter science when I was a
kid so I was a double e
and we learned about Fourier of course
and I can knew all about this Theory but
I didn't know a thing about him
do you
he's he was a French Revolutionary
he got thrown in in jail because he came
a foul of robespier and he was slotted
to get his head guillotined
and he was saved at the last moment by
by rope spear losing his head instead
and then he went off with his new buddy
Napoleon Bonaparte who took a bunch of
savants to Egypt
where he was one of the savants and so
before he was there when the Rosetta
Stone was discovered and later in his
life he uh he mentored champagne who
cracked the hieroglyphics of Egypt using
the Rosetta Stone
he uh but he saw he saw the mistakes
that Napoleon made in military mistakes
that Napoleon made Napoleon got whooped
in England and the last thing that
Napoleon wanted was this loudmouth guy
in Paris telling people what had
actually happened there
so he did the clever thing of
making Fourier the governor of a
province
the prefect of a prefecture the one in
Grenoble
4A knew he was in Exile
and in fact he was there
until
Napoleon got sent off to Saint Helens
Saint Helena and only then it was
Fourier allowed into Paris took over the
French Academy
finally got the math straightened out of
his great theorem which he had plenty of
time to work on there and in the
provinces and this guy durclay helped
him out to get the final final pieces of
math into place
and um
I came up with a greenhouse effect
any Champion Sophie Germaine
first one of the most outstanding female
mathematicians
before anybody would imagine all it
could do could be talented that way
this guy
all right we all know his theory you add
up I just call them waves sine waves of
course you add them up different
frequencies
different amplitudes different phases
how they're adjusted to relatively one
another and you get any one-dimensional
signal in the real world there are some
mathematical beasts you can generate
that
that violate
violate the theory but uh for anything
in the real world like audio like what
we're doing right here you can have
these ways together and get that get
that signal and it works in 2D as well
multiple multiple Dimensions actually
you extrude these waves away from the
screen you get corrugations
and if you look down on those
corrugations they look like this
and the same thing if you add up
corrugations of different frequencies
and different amplitudes different
phases and different angles you can get
any picture
like these or any of the pictures I'm
showing today you can get your picture
of your kid any picture is a sum of
corrugations
kind of surprising in itself but that's
not where the digital world came from
that came from the great sampling
theorem
the sampling theorem is sort of the
centerpiece of this book my book
and uh
I won't explain it to people because
it's just a piece of magic
that makes the whole modern world go
round
as far as sound and pictures go anyhow
the guy I was always told that first I
was told that Harry Nyquist did it no I
didn't
and then I was told Claude Shannon did
it no he didn't he never even claimed he
did it
here's the guy that did it so you know
this is one of my years I went on to
figure out who did the sampling theorem
first and every country has a candidate
and I went through them all and I became
convinced this was the guy his name is
Vladimir patelnikov he's a Russian
he lived through now you may say by the
way that's him Young when he proved the
theorem that's him old when he's
standing in in the Kremlin covered with
all the orders of linen and Stalin and
they read this and they read that and I
cropped him out of the picture but Putin
is right next to him
I got this off of Putin's website
he's being knighted or whatever the
equivalent is in Russia in the Kremlin
for the sampling theorem on his 70th
birthday
and I I know some Russians here in town
and they swear up and down oh yeah he's
the guy you America's never you how come
you always still you don't give him
credit I said well I'm going to I think
he did it
all right let me tell you a little bit
about him his story is so amazing
he
he lived through the
Russian Revolution the Civil War
afterwards both World Wars the Cold War
and basically all the horrible stuff of
Soviet Russia
he
sultanessa told us about the gulag
archipelago and you told us about these
Paradise Islands located in the gulag
call shiroshkas by the people who were
imprisoned in them they were the
intelligentia
the idea being if you
built a bomber or a bomb or a crypt you
saw cryptanalysis you were in prison
therefore the secrets were held by
Mother Russia so
this guy should have been in a swarovska
he was the head of the space program and
he had some and he was their crypto
analysis expert
he wasn't his lab was
it was I know where the Sriracha was
located
northern northern Moscow
why was he not well because he had a
protectorus
a woman named Valeria golub Silva
who had her own University she was first
great intellect
but the reason she could keep him out of
the camp was because
her family was close with Lennon's
family
and her husband was giorgi malinkoff the
guy who took over from Stalin just as
bloody as Stalin took over directly from
a just as bad
so that's what kept Him
all right so wait a minute we can't give
a comedy credit for something as
important as a sampling theorem but yeah
we I think we have to he did it there's
only the only closest uh competitor I
could find for was a guy named Whitaker
in England but Whitaker didn't do the
entire theorem for those of you speak
band pass and low pass you got to do
both of them to approve the theorem in
my book this guy did it okay
um
what is this through
it's a piece of magic
uh
okay if you think of a picture
as being a Rumple sheet
so and you're looking down on to see the
picture where the heights of the rumples
are the brightness color brightnesses of
the picture
and you let that sheet settle down onto
a bed of nails sharp nails
regularly spaced nails
here's what the sampling theorem says
you only have to preserve to preserve
the image you only have to preserve the
samples at the tips of the nails
you go what
you can throw away that Infinity of
other points
if you do it right
that's what the assembly there says
apparently you're throwing away at
Infinity I'll show you why it's only
apparent
and we have a name
for the sample
and pictures they're called pixels
there's the definition
how do you get how do you get back from
the samples to the image that they
represent
well that paper
could tell the cost paper it's in the
lower right there and you can see the
what we call the sync function everybody
calls it I don't call it that my book I
just call it a pixel spreader
because what the theorem says is take
your samples
put a copy of the spreader function at
each sample adjust its height so it
matches the height of the sample
but the width stays constant
add up the results
you've got the image back
so the magic the the infinity that we
seem to have lost is carried in that
that little mountain this is the
two-dimensional version of that
of the sink function
if you I I dropped a yellow teeth
through its peak so you can see that
it's a peak and a and some negative
lobes and stuff okay all right
that's the magic of the modern picture
world
pixels you can't see if you listen to me
I've just told you it's a point
I can't see a point so one of the first
things I want you to go away with is you
can't see pixels
this is full of billions of pixels and
you can't see any of them right
they're all they're bits in a file
if you want to see one
you asked for it and something happens
and there's the picture what's happened
right there well what's happened is a
very fast calculation because computers
are now fast enough to do it fast
and the little glowy things
the little Hills or the little glowy
things are raised in rows and columns on
the on your display device those aren't
pixels those are display elements
they're analog
they're driven digitally but they're
analog they have a shake more or less
like that made of light
so those display elements are the Recon
or the or this are the pixel spreaders
for the pixels that you can't see
now if you put that in math form it just
looks hairy as I'll get out
all right so I brought up the next
secret of the modern world as you all
know it's the computer
um
yes leibniz did do something about it
and
Ada love listed something about it and
babe it's just something about it but
the guy who nailed it was Alan Turing
just absolutely nailed it
he not only invented
the stored program computer
but he showed us the weirdest weird
things that are out there
in computation land
the fact that
we can't even tell
that I started to say he
he showed us the halting problem no he
didn't you know who showed us the
halting problem
Martin Davis
now Martin's embarrassed to say that
yeah he knew he had done it first but he
didn't want to take you know it was such
a trivial modification of the printing
problem that Turing did did solve that
he would be was embarrassed for anybody
to say that he did the halting problem
in public but I don't have any problems
celebrating my friend he named to prove
the halting problem all right
computations are deterministic
in the small but undetermined in the
large and we are just now I think in the
world starting to encounter just what
strangest us that's going to give lead
us to
Connie will you for understanding what
how it works
all right so
there was one guy in the world
who knew immediately what Turing had
done and it was Johnny Von Neumann
he was one smart fellow
he this is how smart he was he he
happened to hear girdle present took
incompleteness through and gotten good
and he went to him the next day and said
I've got an improvement
for your theorem
and girdle said no I've already approved
that sorry and that and if I know I've
been kind of showing you his personality
I think didn't do logic any refused to
do any further logic he got out girdled
by girdle okay
but I love this picture which his
daughter gave me
because it shows him in a business suit
the only guy in a business suit on a at
the edge of the Grand Canyon with no hat
and his mule is fake while he's sitting
ass backwards right on the edge of the
Grand Canyon
but both of these guys he knew exactly
what Turing had done and he knew as
Turing did that the only way that you
know attorney oh I should stop him
and show you something where is that
yeah
for this book
I think I'm going to show you that next
slide yeah
I designed a universal turing machine
as a business card I've got a bunch of
them up here if you want one later
okay
it'll compute anything that's computable
in the universe
very slowly
the old compute Toy Story for example
but it might take the lifetime of the
universe to do it
so he so these both these guys
understood that
and by the way I I said
touring invented the stored program
computer a lot of Engineers claim the
engineers no this guy did it and I
explained it in my book chapter three
which Martin Davis helped me with
um
there it is program memory data memory
programming CPU it's all there it was
but it was software and it was awfully
slow
but he and far Norman knew as nearly
everybody does so you want something in
software to go fast you turn it into
Hardware
we all know that and they rushed off
both of them to do that
so I came up with two versions of this
turing machine here's my I don't want
you to pay attention to the details here
I just want to show you how I present
history in my book it turns out the
simple Narrative of some genius and does
it all it just doesn't work
it's always a family tree of people who
borrow ideas from each other and stab
each other in the back and you know do
all kinds of of things
to to have the results come out as we
know they do in this case yeah Alan
Turing is up at the top on computable
numbers is more importantly is at the
very top
his paper 1936 paper and Von Norman is
right there because he saw it almost
immediately and uh everything
desensitive right you follow tearing
down you come to the hardware the first
computers and I mean stored program
computers not calculating machines they
don't count eniac for example is not a
computer
originally yeah it wasn't stored program
there's an eniac plus up there it's a
different thing but I know I haven't
looked at any accidents if you add some
Hardware to this thing it'll be stored
program
and there's the actual so I celebrate
baby
this guy is the first computer
uh I was kind of surprised when I wrote
this book I couldn't tell you who had
built the first computer
really
it's been all my life here and I don't
know
and that's because I decided it was just
a matter of definition if you define it
to be a star program computer it just
falls out one two three four you can see
who did it
and baby was the first or perhaps eniac
plus they're fighting there's a lot of
battles
but they're you know they're within two
or three weeks or months of each other
they're really cool I just call it a tie
the only thing that Turing worked on was
a failure
that he got fired from the job
but Von Neumann influenced every other
computer up there
all right so
I went to visit baby for my book
baby was built in Manchester England
it's in a the most Museum of Science and
Industry in Manchester
and uh this is how it greeted me
and the word Pixar was scrolling to the
right
so the important thing is the first
computer
possibly in a second
half pixels and it could animate
boy was that a surprise to me
1947 48. way before I saw computer
Graphics has started
okay
here's the actual first picture
first pixels that the Tom Kilburn who
built baby took the first picture I call
it first light the first digital image
by the way no little squares right
never have been
and I found also Manchester the first
game interactive game
it's checkers
and uh
it's interactive because again this is
this is 51. this is at least a decade
earlier than the claims were about the
history of computer graphics and
interactive computer graphics
all right
this chart again don't pay too much
attention I just want you to notice the
red arrow at the top that connects to
the previous chart
and I have a bunch of these charts they
just they're they're threads that you
know integrate in different ways to
generate the modern world and this one I
just want you to look at I just want to
pick out a couple of
see her see the guys safer in the Nazis
in the upper right
one of them is Herbert whoops sorry
one of them is Herbert Freeman
he was my chairman my first job at NYU
it must have been amazing he turned out
to be one of the founding fathers of
computer graphics he was saved from the
from the Nazis by Adolf Hitler no no no
no
wrong sensor by Albert Einstein himself
Albert Einstein wrote three letters in
this kid's behalf
and he managed to get him out of Germany
in 39 just in time
and I was working for this guy and he he
knew I was an artist and he said Alfie
why don't you come join us in our
computer Graphics research and I said
this I'm still embarrassed but I said
herb if you ever get color I'm there
it was all black and white then so I
kind of blew off an opportunity
but the only thing I really want you to
see the time is proceeding down here I
want you to see that
just barely there it says Moore's Law
I want to make my Morris laws pitch
because to me this is this is one of the
most important things in our modern
world
Gordon Moore so we've been talking about
what I call Epic one
you see maybe in the lower lower left
this is the period when as the computers
got more powerful they got larger and
larger and larger until they were
several stories tall and they weigh tons
in costs today's money billions of
dollars and they were really dumb really
in today's standards and then in 65
the year I came to Stanford just made
the picture for the newest weather
satellite
Gordon Moore stood up at Intel and said
something that was unintelligible to me
so I put it in terms that are
intelligible to everybody I think he
said you know the density of components
on an integrated circuit ship will
double every 18 months or so
okay what's that mean
uh it doesn't mean anything to me until
I put it in equivalent terms
so doubling in a year and a half is the
same thing almost exactly as an order of
a factor of ten five years
and everything good about computers is
directly related to the density of
components of an integrated circuit chip
so my version which I think is much more
meaningful and helpful is everything
good anything good about computers gets
better by an order of magnitude every
every five years
and I say order of magnitude instead of
factor of 10 because
we puny humans max out at an order of
magnitude we can't imagine Beyond an
order of magnitude or maybe some of us
can but not two orders of magnitude or
three
so it's a conception conceptions change
at an order of magnitude
and if you look at that curve
we are now okay so Gordon Moore said
he only had four data points
and he says you know I think this might
last for for 10 years
well here we are
11 orders of magnitude away from Gordon
War
no genius can think that
none of us none of you I'm sure some
really smart people here can think I
have an organism magnitude ahead and
we're just we're a couple years now
we're going to hit
12 orders
what's that feel like you don't know
until we get there
it's like
like the halting problem you know what
their sea is going to Halt until you get
there and find out that it didn't and
you still still are asking
okay by the way the engineers
making those denture chips are writing
the same curve they can't see or
magnitude Beyond either
in my lifetime I've seen the I've heard
the Moore's Law the death of Moore's Law
prophesied four or five times
but every time the engineers say they
get the one order menu they went oh
I think I see how we can push it on
now we may really have reached there now
to reached the limit but I I'm skeptical
I want to repeat this because this is
this this is the Supernova that has
driven the modern Digital World the
revolution that we all everybody here
has lived through
and I use the word Supernova on purpose
the Supernova is a star that explodes
and becomes 10 billion times brighter
than the original Star
you see I'm talking about
an explosion that's already a hundred
billion times
brighter than the original Star and
heading for a trillion
this is the PowerHouse that has driven
everything that you and I do I've served
this tour my whole life
and I think I think there everybody
living today will probably do the same
thing
unless it dies
all right what did Moore's Law bring my
particular field of computer Graphics it
brought us color pixels
they didn't exist
and in 1960 I went in search of them and
I found them here they are for my book I
had to find them I found them and they
happened seven years before I thought
they did
on the Simulator for the Apollo Moon
project
and I found the tool Engineers who've
done it and we spent a fabulous seven
hours together in Salt Lake City until
we nailed the actual moment that it
happened
and Not only was it the first color of
pixels but it was the first 3D shaded
color graphics
and only that but it was in real time
because these were a simulator for NASA
so
Moore's law that was one of those first
fruits
all right again this chart joints to the
last one I don't really want you to
spend too much time thinking about it
let me just
at the very top on the leathers rod
ruscello and Bob Schumacher those are
the two gentlemen that brought us the
color pixels okay
um
I really want to point to this
particular braid threading of all those
braids is the one I know best and I'll
talk a little bit about that
but if you read across the bottom you
see Toy Story ants and Ice Age across
the bottom
all the other moving companies
came alive about the same time that we
did and they were just different
threadings of these different braidings
of these threads
got us there
all right
this is this is the paint program at
Xerox Park this is where I finally got
my color pixels
I broke my leg in New York
skiing
and while I was in this full body cast
for three months
I decided that Academia wasn't the right
thing for me
yeah I was doing I was not honoring my
art
and that's the right thing to do and
this shocked my academic colleagues
that was to come out of the cast and
announced that I was leaving Academia
and I was going to California where
something good would happen and it was
that ill thought
I really did I just I just did it
I'm shocked at how lame that thinking
was but I did it
and what happened was
came to Berkeley
lived on the floor with Gene Lawler some
of you may know him and uh
uh
hung out with pop Tartan I had room to
Bob tarjan and you know I can't remember
where I met all these the blooms I met
all these people that you all know and
uh
you know it's what keep me in a sense
kept me part of your community although
I'm really not you know I was doing
computer graphics and movies by then or
I was on the path that would lead to
that and the where it started was right
here at Xerox Park
my friend dick shop had built a pay
program
painting that's me I looked at it
and I said that's me it's painting it's
color
and I got myself hard on it as fast as I
could at Xerox park it happened to be
the Heyday of Xerox Park where the where
the
the desktop of computation as we now
know it was being invented Mouse and
windows based UI and laser printer and
you know the whole thing
and color pixels
but Xerox fired me
oh oh but I added the H RGB to HSP color
transform while I was there uh I
couldn't think in RGB
uh
I asked my boss why are you firing he
said well we we've decided not to do
color
I said what yeah he says you you own it
I mean I didn't know about the NASA guys
here but I thought this was the only
color pixels in the world says you own
it completely and that's the future he
says
you may be right Alvey but we made a
corporate decision to go black and white
okay bye
and I we had the so my buddy David
DeFrancisco and I had cast our Lots
together to to submit a proposal to the
National Endowment for the Arts
to to make art using this new we called
it raster Graphics this new medium this
new way of making pictures
but we needed a frame buffer we needed a
color pixel memory the first one had
just been pulled away from me
we had to find the next frame buffer
and we found the next one hadn't been
built yet but we found out that this
rich man on the North Shore or Long
Island
not him but him
at a place called New York Institute of
Technology his name is Alex sure the guy
on the right
had bought
the next frame buffer
and we got ourselves there as fast as we
could this school is a this school in
this man were amazing it's all a bunch
of mansions on the North fabulous North
Shore The Great Gatsby part of Long
Island
and he had a 100 person old-fashioned
cell animation team there making tubby
the tuba and he thought he could put
computers in there and fire all the
videos don't say that no you can't do
that it doesn't work like that
and anyhow
first thing he did for us was buy us the
first 24-bit pixels in the world
I had I explained to him and I don't
know where he got it if you put
three of these 8-bit thingies together
you have a 24 bit thingy by the way the
8-Bit thingies cost eighty thousand
dollars each in seventy five dollars
nineteen seventy five dollars
and he I didn't know what he understood
what I said or not he came and you go
for 256 colors to 16 million as we could
do anything with 16 million dollars
he came in one I said okay
I've watched five more of those eight
bit things so you'd have two of those 24
bit things and basically he put us out
in front of the world but we never
looked back I met Ed catmore there he
and I invented the alpha Channel because
we could think about if we had enough
memory we could think about adding a
fourth Channel without any
it was easy for us to think it and uh
started making amazing amounts of Art
I did this piece called Sunstone there
with Adam schwiller I'm the black-haired
guy by the way
this is sort of the limits of what we
could do in 79 just six polygons texture
maps and anti-alias but only six
computers are really slow still
and uh we decided that
this guy was not the guy to pin our
wagon to he he was tell me the tuba was
terrible it was a flop
so George Lucas called
Sid come join me and of course we did we
left there and waited for George to and
I started hiring all the best guys in
the world
and uh waiting for George to come and
ask me to be in his next movie he never
came
oh my God he doesn't get it
and it took Star Trek
producers showing up and using
industrial Light Magic as their special
effects house
for Star Trek II The Wrath of Khan to
get I and my team on the big screen for
the first time with a 60-second piece
and this there's these are some frames
from that piece
um but George
oh that so that came out and uh
82.
Ed catmore and I
uh
who would start Pixar together
decided in 83 that we would be the first
people in the world we should announce
to the world that we did character
animation not science fiction cowboy
stuff
and this is where
my my dinner with my breakfast with
Andre comes in
um this is four successive frames from
this piece I just heard a first-rate
animator Talent named John Lasseter and
directed him in this piece but what I
want to show you is we had solved motion
blur we had to solve this we worked on
it for years we knew if we didn't solve
motion blur we would never be success
because it's another it's another
sampling problem if you don't sample
correctly in time you get
shaggies you get temporal jaggies
your pictures jutter across the street
and you can't stand looking at them
some of the Geniuses that I had hired at
lucasfilm solved that problem and here's
our first time out
and in this piece
kind of
is the holy
icon of that time it's called 1984 was
completely fake
but we had solved everything we needed
to solve in order to go big time
and uh
for this book I realized something else
that we've been
doing all along but
nobody ever put into words before as we
were honoring the central dogma what I
call the central dogma we will model
inside the computer using
3D euclidean geometry
we will use Newtonian
physics for gravity and Optics
and we will take the 3D into 2D using
Renaissance perspective
now everybody just did that they didn't
even think about it
so
but I came from the artistic world and
we we're not bound by any of that and
computers aren't Bound by any of those
three things so you know one of my jobs
in the world is urge artist please break
out of the central dogma and show us
what else is out there
and that and I use this picture in my
book as an example of non
non-renaissance perspective
uh you know because the beam's been here
here but they don't in a Renaissance
perspective
um I think I should start wrapping it up
right
okay yeah so
um I'll skip over the almost movie we
didn't make
but it was the movie uh it was based on
The Monkey King literature of Asia
that I'm a particular fan of
and I had to back out of it because I
sat down and did the numbers right at
the last minute and discovered oh we
need another five years of Moore's Law
we're still shy and that was good timing
because right at that point George and
Marshall Lucas got divorced
George lost half his fortune overnight
I went to Ed and I said Ed we've got to
start a company and create a home for
these for these geniuses
George just doesn't have enough money to
afford us anymore
now this is two nerds talking to each
other we weren't business guys at all
he said what should we let's show we
what shall the company do we knew we
couldn't do movies because we just had
that
experiment with The Monkey King that
said you we need five more years before
Moore's law will be at movie level
well well we had built a hardware
machine called the Pixar image computer
for George let's turn that prototype
into a product and that'll make enough
money to support our group
long enough we think for Moore's law to
it right and that's what we did
uh and you know the rest of the story
Toy Story five years later
right on Moore's Law curve Disney
knocked on our door and said guys let's
make that movie you always wanted to
make and of course it was Toy Story
and almost it was almost exactly at the
moment it's actually 95 so just shy of
the Millennium and then ants came out
from the DreamWorks group and Ice Age
from the Blue Sky group also within
pleasure mice a few years of the
millennium
um
I can talk about the future but maybe
I'll save that for questioning I think
I'll stop there
and open it up for questions
[Applause]
microphones too
run around here
okay
well let's put that up as maybe you'll
wonder what that is
uh you mentioned the story of the
tyrants and the innovators
as you've observed Computing turned into
the internet
where did it go wrong
from your perspective
uh
I'm still watching and observing I'm not
convinced that we can't bring it back
under you know uh I I my wife and I talk
about this a lot you know when the when
the printing press first showed up
it was so disruptive
just horrible stuff was being printed
and some people say the French
Revolution came right out of that
there's horrible things that got said
about Marie Antoinette for example
um but finally you know mechanisms came
into play they're not necessarily in
play but there were mechanisms that came
into play
of editing and and selection by more
talented people and where things were
presented in a careful way and there was
fact checking you know there came a way
now will the same thing arise for the
internet I don't know but I still have
my hopes there uh I
of course I've been tracking all this
you know we back at New York Tech we had
we had this new thing called email
at one point
and we thought it was the most amazing
thing in the world we could write each
other letters at different universities
and just and we it was ours nobody else
had it
and then one day everybody had it damn
and that's an awful thing you know I
can't I'm starting through an email
constantly I hate it
but I have to have it right so
um
of course we're all looking at
well I guess we all are I am chat GPT
and and the visual equivalent uh
let me see
let me show you
oh I already took it down
um
I I don't know where that's going I
think it's a huge advance
I think it's a lever of some sort
that once we've
wrapped our heads around it we'll do
amazing things with it it's going to
transform whatever happens from here on
out a lot
it's one of those things you could not
see before or Moore's Law because you
just had to get there when the computers
got big enough and fast enough and the
memories are huge enough you could put
everything in the memory and look
through it it took that before things
like chat GPT could show up we're just
there it seems like a nightmare right
now but
I'm more optimistic than that but let's
hope it's true
let's hope I can be
uh
so to follow up on that a little bit you
know as Moore's Law continue to improve
more and more uh over here
um we're here here
oh there you are okay yeah
um so you know well potentially
everything can be virtualized you know
going to VR
um you know very closely related to
computer Graphics
um
really okay so what do you think about
vrs our future
oh I think I think we're coming gone
you know I mean it's just it's just one
of the tools now
uh three or four years ago I was totally
excited about it
in fact I am an advisor to a startup
company in the valley called bail buff
Studios is VR company
and uh I put this picture up here
because it's by an older artist friend
of mine named Darcy gerberg in New York
who's been using my paint program for
decades and to tell you truth I didn't
much like her stuff until she got to
VR she started using a tool called tilt
brush
where you can paint
in three space
these Strokes you see here in the
foreground are all painted in three
space you choose the color and the paint
Strokes honor the central dogma they're
they have width and texture and they
cast shadows in each other and all the
things that happen in central dogma land
but then she looks at
the world like her Studio or her living
room through the sculpture she's painted
and digitizes that and brings it into
Photoshop and does artistic things to it
and gets things like this out of it and
all of a sudden I find myself just
sucked into her paintings for the first
time and I'm really like them and if I
got
she just sent me this picture this
morning of another VR painting that
she's made and she's looking through it
at that picture I just showed you
hanging on the wall in her
you know and she's being shown all over
the all over the world she's you know
all of a sudden she's really hot
but that's
that she was doing that now we got
Chachi well uh let's call it Dali and
that is
stable diffusion or let me show you this
one
um this is uh
damn
well one not only that we've mentioned
mid-journey thank you mid Journey
version four
um I'm I'm not I don't put this up
because I think it's good stuff I put
this up because I got it off of Twitter
somebody just posted it said they had
mid-journey they gave mid Journey the
instruction the U.S presidents to look
like Pixar characters
and got this out
and I'm you know whatever you think
about them I'm looking at this and
saying even one of those
would probably take me a week to execute
and this guy just sat down and
and not only that so you see the top
middle is Teddy Roosevelt he sent
several variations of Teddy Roosevelt
which case he had given extra
Instructions make throw in a teddy bear
and Teddy Roosevelt and Pixar character
and you got sort of a
oh fast so it's an amplifier this is an
amplifier and yes there's going to be
lots of garbage comes out of it but
there's lots of garbage that gets
painted every day too but some of my art
experience are extremely excited they
said oh Elvis
you can go through ideas at 90 miles an
hour and ever saw your job as a artist
as an editor a selector the person who
finds the jewel in all the all the crap
and pulls that out and says take a look
at this folks
so I I think or I think we're in I'm
pretty sure where we're launched already
into a major art explosion because it's
all in the hands of individuals now
who don't have to have Pixar to back
them up I'm expecting garagebands now to
do amazing to do movies
because there's the Unreal Engine came
out a few years ago
well the Unreal Engine can do in real
time what we used to just dream of doing
at lucasfilm 80 million polygons in a
picture
we thought that was the limit I mean if
we could do 80 million polygons we were
in the right realm of making people
happy in the audience
and we would wait 50 hours to get one
such picture
real time on real dozen real time does
all the lighting and the shadowing and
everything
awesome now I could tell you by Moore's
law that number would get there
but what it actually feels like is a
total surprise because I can't see I
can't do that order of magnitude thing
so put put tools of that kind of
leverage into the hands of
billions of artists I think amazing
things are going to happen I know some
of the major museums are already gearing
up for shows too years from now
where they want to show what generative
AI does and so forth
well let me get that off the screen
the Darcy's picture back so one of your
slides had uh billiard balls and they
were so realistic I couldn't tell if
they were computer generated they had
the reflections of the overhead lights
on them
uh what was uh what's the real story
behind those billiard balls all right so
that's totally fake
uh it's modeled did you fall as a
central dogma it's modeled with very
simple euclidean geometry we're using uh
the motion that Newton would say would
happen if one ball hits another ball
there's the action reaction stuff and
we've got motion blurs and we've got the
Shadows from several light sources all
doing the right things and yes if you
look if you look at the close-up on the
right side of the four ball
you can see a guy holding pill cue in
the window and there's a palm tree out
the door and there's some beer beer
signs on the walls you know once you get
there you can just do anything
but we had to get there in 1984 it just
suddenly Moore's Law suddenly got there
and we were off and running
uh you've mentioned a lot of like
Moore's Law as well as things like AI uh
in the last few minutes how much do you
think
the kind of future of graphics and
Computing is dependent on
that Hardware acceleration or on like
software do you think it's just the
hardware and the software catches up or
do you think that the software no I
think it's a storytellers you know a lot
of things are just tools it's the
storytellers you know when I so okay I'm
an artist of sorts
yeah
I thought I was an animator
and until I found out I wasn't
and how I found out was
Andre and Wally B
I drew the storyboards
and I started executing the thing also I
realized this is kind of boring
you know and I and about that moment I
met John Lasseter on a visit to Disney
and we found out he was available and I
snapped him up
and he came to work for us and he said
Alvin can I make a few suggestions he
looked at my storyboard yeah I said
that's why you're here basically he took
over he took over the animation of Andre
and added wallaby to it and made him
cued and animated and flexible and
he could so what does the great animator
have that I don't I can make things move
but I can't convince you that they're
alive and conscious and feel pain
animators can do that
I think they have the same skill as
great actors
in fact I've talked to both groups and
they both say all right
Brian Cox the star of succession I had
dinner with anyone I asked him about
this he said oh yeah that's why I set up
an animation studio animation class in
my uh in Dundee where I'm from would you
give a talk there yeah I will
um
you think about what an actor or actress
an actor or actress does they convince
you that their body is somebody else is
completely different from who they
really are
and the if they're good actors they're
totally convincing
if they're bad you pick it up in a
moment
same with animation if the animator is
good they're absolutely convincing and
if they're bad you pick up it just
doesn't work
and I does anybody know how that works
can you replace an animator or an actor
I don't think so at least there's no
clue how you do it yet
uh part of me says yeah we
there's got to be a machine that works
somehow that we can understand it just
has to be
but
you know back at Stanford when I started
yeah you know by the way I stopped
studying hey after about two years I
said this is not going to happen in my
lifetime
I think I might be wrong there but maybe
not I still you know things are still
kind of kind of weird I'm looking to use
Theory guys to tell me what's out in
this weird land
of of uh you know where you know most of
my career in computers in programming we
were weren't allowed to compute on a
program
the system wouldn't let you do it
while I'm pretty sure that's what these
nets are doing is they're Computing on
themselves and now we're off in these
really weird spaces that give us GPT and
Dolly and so forth
let me give you an example
hmm
my wife and I were in Cambridge England
on one of her sabbaticals
at King's College tourings college
wonderful sabbatical and my one of my
old buddies walked up to me and he said
hey Alvey we don't have to program
anymore
what do you mean he said read this paper
and he handed me a paper which happens
to be from Berkeley
that I call the zebra's horses paper
um
which says
take again a a neural net of a certain
variety and train it with 1 000
arbitrary pictures of horses and one
thousand arbitrary pictures of zebras an
efforts trained appropriately you can
give it a picture like the one on the
top left
and it'll spit out the picture at the
top right it'll replace the zebras with
a horse
sort of horse
unless you look closely or vice versa
give it a arbitrary horse picture it'll
spit out that horse replaced with a
zebra and I said well
how does it do that that's not a more
well-posed problem is it I what's a
horse what's a zebra how did they know
he says that's what I'm trying to tell
you we don't know how it works it just
doesn't
and it's too complex to reverse engineer
it that's the part I want you Theory
guys to figure out
what's going on in there can we get
better hold on that strange
the strange the strange parts of
computation Theory
because I think we're there
so
regretting the the central dogma what
are some interesting ways that you've
seen people break it in some ways in
which people haven't broken it yet but
you think would be cool to explore well
let me just start programs they don't
honor the central government at all you
can put any color in anything so you
want to
that's what painters always have done
just anything they want on the canvas so
to speak right so there's nothing about
central dogma
uh hampering painting and that's that's
one of the reasons I've had so
back in the early days when I give talks
people would say Ellie it's your goal to
simulate reality I would no
no
reality is just interesting subject you
know uh but no and then I realized you
know a lot of my colleagues actually are
very interested in simulating reality so
I had to kind of tone that down a little
bit
um
I had another answer for you let's see
oh where's where it's broken uh so I
said all whether I said this or not but
in all movies
that have been made so far
uh are Central dogmatic
except one scene
in one Pixar movie
breaks out of the central dogma it's
Soul you've seen Soul there's a
there's a pre-islander a pre-location
where the souls are before they
come to be associated with
bodies on Earth
and they wanted to show that that was a
different kind of place and the way they
chose to do it was have to violate
Newtonian physics so the hidden Services
don't
hide each other they they show
intersections and instead of occlusions
yeah
kind of worked it was a kind of nifty
but that's the only place where the only
purpose they violated it
CAD cam which is
the part of my world part of computer
Graphics that is all about the objects
not about pictures
depends on central dogma because their
picture their things are going to exist
in the real world
I think that's why it was such a just
assumption by so many people in computer
Graphics because a lot of the people in
the early days were doing cat cam
designing airplanes and cars and so
forth
and those things have to work in the
real world therefore they have to honor
the central dogma
um
I guess that's enough of the answer
a quick one hi
um where do you see interactivity
fitting in storytelling
I'm not sure about that one you know you
know at bail Bob
we had an interactive you know that you
put on the goggles and you can interact
and you know for years I've heard about
you know choosing different outcomes
depending on interactivity and they
never quite seem to work very well for
one thing it's really hard to write the
screenplay
I mean one screenplay is hard enough but
if if you don't quite know which path
people are going to take then it becomes
well that's why these really successful
games have been worked on for years to
get all the possible to have something
happen in all the possible
uh branchings
but it's it's it's so hard to do I mean
I guess the games are a good example for
that
where interactivity is everything and uh
uh it controls gameplay
I'm not a game guy so
but all my grandkids are Fanatics so
um thank you for the talk that was
amazing I was just wondering how you uh
chose your area of um cellular automaton
and your grad school where if you were
interested in animation before or like
yeah what kind of factory well uh
tell you the truth I thought it had
something to do with living things I
mean just punting on the word cell and
cellular
it's not a very good it doesn't really
map on the living things but that's kind
of what inspired phenomena right and
ulum to write their book in the first
place was
things floating in a sea of nutrients
and they would come together and then he
decided to so cellular automata
formalism kind of captured the notion of
a sea of nutrients in a controllable way
that you could prove theorems about but
in the process of doing that kind of
lost all touch with real life
but I did I used to sit around and think
about well maybe I could design an egg
that was a cellular automaton that would
grow
and as far as I got with that idea was
Stephen Levy put it in as a front of
quote in one of his books and that was
the end of that so
I just haven't had a lot of ideas I just
didn't pursue that was one
I still think there's something there I
grew plants using uh uh lindenmeyer
systems which are
they're not cellular automata but
they're they're formal systems that make
pictures and you can grow plants and
trees and things and I was fascinated by
Linda Meyer systems for a long time in
Houston animations
oh uh hello
um so
um I guess currently I'm an
undergraduate and I guess um I could
definitely relate in the um being both
in the artistic and academic field space
um my dad's a math professor and I grew
up like with um a strong math background
but I was also like really really
interested in art so I guess my question
is like a little more simpler but
um I guess what did you study during
your undergraduate
um education and also how did you
balance that with your art and
yeah I didn't do a good job
I was a double e because the double e
got more math than a math major and more
physics than a physics major and you can
get a job that pays after you know I
grew up fairly you know not real poor
but poorly and I need to think about
things like a job later and
yeah
I'm not doing a good job answering this
what I want to say is
math and art really are kind of alike in
a lot of ways they're absolutely
stunningly gorgeous when you're
deep in the heart of both of them
you know what I mean those of you who
prove beautiful theorems you know what I
mean
yeah thank you so much for that talk
that was uh that was really wonderful
um one question I had as you were
talking
um you brought up Moore's Law a lot and
you said that there was at least one
instance where I think it was after the
uh you wanted to make Monkey King you
realize that you need to wait five years
for Moore's law to catch up or be
realized and it made me wonder whether
like reflecting back whether there were
many points in time where you reflected
on Moore's Law throughout your career
and
um yeah I guess if you have anything to
yeah Ed Campbell who's my partner the
co-founder of Pixar with me and I used
compute more you know we we would use
Warsaw all the time to see when are we
going to get there
I didn't have my really handy version
order magnitude version
until I wrote the book darn it but I
could I could figure it out the
old-fashioned way even though it was
painful
um and I yeah I sat down monkey was a
big disappointment because
I'd gone to China in 1978 and I came
back you know just after Nixon had been
there basically and I came back with
this many volumes of monkey stories and
and artworks and when this Japanese firm
came and said we want to make the first
movie with you guys and want to base it
on monkey I said
somebody's just grabbed me by their neck
yes sir that's what we'll do uh I'm so
disappointed we got a long ways John
Laster started drawing sketches of what
the monkey character would look like and
it was only after several months that I
sat down said well I better figure out
what to charge this company
and I sharpened my pencil and pulled in
everything nobody ever costed
a 3D computer Graphics movie before
so I decided
everything I spent Years Learning
put a price to it put a time to it
come up with a reasonable number to
charge this company
assuming that we were there and I was
really
disadmillion when I found out we weren't
it was going to take
three years to compute that was the
killer they didn't they couldn't wait
three years for anything and it's going
to cost twice as much as it
as they could possibly afford and so I I
bit the bullet
took the loss of face myself
and just said we can't do it yet sorry
backed away
my question was also about Moore's Law
and kind of how you like waited five
years to make Toy Story until the
technology progressed there was like a
clip of like Hayao Miyazaki at CEO
Ghibli and he's shown like a CG
animation and saying that that's kind of
the death of animation and that he
prefers hand-drawn so I was kind of
wondering like how you balance
um like advancing technology and also
like keeping like the touch of a human
artist
and like traditional artwork as well
well I probably very highly uh in fact
I'm kind of one of the things that makes
me kind of sad with my own
technology this 3D
computer Graphics is old 2D cell
animations just died
you know that's a beautiful art form
and it it shouldn't die that should be
exploited in fact one of the things I
didn't tell you about we one of the
first relationships we had with Disney
was to digitize the cell animation
process
Ed and I used to go on pilgrimages every
year to Disney Center you guys ready for
us yet and they would always say no
because they were run by a football
player for many years
Los Angeles Ram he married Disney's
daughter that was his qualification and
they would always always say no they
would say can you boys do bubbles and we
would that you're no can you next year
can you do smoke well no you know they
didn't get it there we could do anything
sooner or later pay for us to get there
and they they could have had us for
nothing
and he ended up paying 7 billion
I don't get it you know
[Laughter]
we're kind of coming to the end of the
talk I actually have a question uh you
know you spend a lot of time uh
beautifully sort of showing the history
in the sense of where is the first place
that something was invented you know the
software the hardware and so forth but
you know one of the things that's
happening
um is that an artist is using these
programs in what's whose is it do they
own it anymore are they the first uh
well I've actually thought about this
for many years and uh remember the
picture I showed you of the first RGB
pictures the guy who bought us the
you know basically pay two million
dollars on my say so to get us enough
memory to make RGB
um
damn I lost my track there
yeah
Who's the artist okay
now I've got it okay see the upper right
picture
it's my piece but it's made from the
UFOs by Jim Bland
uh David DeFrancisco took the photograph
of us Stonehenge that I use Paul sander
was a painter that used my paint program
to paint the clouds and the grasses
uh Lance Williams contributed the Chrome
piece
another guy wrote the function generator
that I used for the streaking glass
I put it all together it's my piece
I call it a one frame movie I called it
back then I called it a one frame movie
if I give credits for this thing
it's like a movie you gotta list off
every machine you use and every artist
and their contribution but there's no
doubt in my mind or any of my colleagues
that this is my piece I was the one that
arranged it and got the pieces together
I directed this one frame movie it's my
piece and I think we're going to start
applying that idea again
thank you
to an amazing
[Music]
[Applause]